[Music]
take a moment to think about the
appearance of a modern bird
like a parrot or something similar we
know these animals have
relatively thick bodies feathery coats
unique patterns
and varying colors now let's look at a
parrot skeleton
you'll notice that based on the bones
alone these birds seem like they'd have
long slender frames
yet the layers of skin and feather
coverings make them look quite different
than their gaunt skeletal structures
might suggest and this exact phenomenon
presents a practical challenge when it
comes to reconstructing accurate
depictions
of dinosaurs an increasing number of
soft tissue discoveries have suggested
that many though not all
species of dinosaurs possess more
feathers layers of fat
and other unusual details than one might
assume based on the outdated depictions
many of us grew up with
the challenge of capturing the forgotten
peculiarities of dinosaurs is at the
center of all yesterdays
a book written and illustrated in part
by cm koziman whose work you may
recognize from his other most famous
book
all tomorrows the 2012 speculative art
book all yesterdays was created not just
by kozman however but also darren naish
an expert paleontologist and author
and john conway a skilled paleo artist
these three are brilliant and have links
to where you can follow and support them
in this video's description
not long ago i covered a section of this
book titled all todays
in which the authors imagine what might
happen if millions of years into the
future
clueless alien scientists tried to
recreate depictions of long extinct
organisms based solely on the fossil
record
with pretty hilarious results but i
can't emphasize enough
that despite misconceptions to the
contrary all yesterdays isn't trying to
belittle the field of paleontology with
these images
or suggest modern scientists are
similarly clueless when it comes to
reconstructing dinosaurs
paleoart has come a long way thanks in
part to the efforts of these creators
three authors all of whom are deeply
involved in the paleontology community
themselves
make it clear that modern
paleontologists aren't just blindly
interpreting fossils but also making
great strides in integrating studies of
feather impressions and soft tissue
preservation
to gain more complete pictures of what
these incredible creatures might have
looked like
however like with any science there is
still of course a diversity of
fascinating unknowns when it comes to
dinosaurs
and all yesterday's explores how
speculation as long as it's cautiously
grounded in science can both help
and even play a vital role in showcasing
the intriguing possibilities of how
dinosaurs might have looked and behave
all yesterday's stress is a balance
between caution and speculation
always pointing out that many of the
reconstructions within the pages
might be completely off the mark that's
just the nature of speculation with that
said
let's get started and take a closer look
at what unique aspects of dinosaurs may
not show up in the fossil record
the first out of the norm reconstruction
of a dinosaur all yesterday's explorers
is of a carnotaurus
drawn at a unique angle by john conway
while the bullheaded predators are
usually depicted from the side
here the authors depict the animal
head-on drawing attention to just how
strange the animal looks
with his arms stuck out to the side in a
bizarre display the idea behind this
strange spectacle comes from the animal
skeleton which shows the animal had
stunted
ineffectual arms yet possessed unique
shoulders which would have allowed the
animals to spread these arms out
sideways in a way utterly dissimilar to
other
large predatory dinosaurs an ability
which seems to serve no
practical purpose so the authors imagine
the arms on the carnotaurus and the
related majungasaurus
pictured here in cm cozman's
one-of-a-kind style were waved about
in mating or territorial displays
potentially alongside bright colors
not unlike many birds today a bizarre
concept for sure
but not altogether improbable given the
available paleontological data
of course some dinosaur colors might
have also gone in the opposite direction
can you see the majungasaurus in this
image how about now
here the authors explore the possibility
that some dinosaurs might have had
appearances which supported camouflage
in mimicry
blending into the natural features of
the environment much like a modern stick
bug
now it's usually smaller animals not
predators like majungasaurus which
employ camouflage
but some large modern predators body
patterns like the tiger's distinctive
stripes which allow them to blend into
tall grasses do help them
ambush prey so it's certainly possible
some dinosaurs might have had
similar camouflaged appearances here's
another recreation which
at first might be difficult to see this
is all yesterday's speculative concept
for police leasoria portraying the
animal with impressive camouflage
strange though this might seem to anyone
familiar with traditional portrayals of
plesiosauria
the modern oceans are swarming with
remarkable forms of mimicry
just look at the incredible appearance
of something like a leafy sea dragon
and you'll start to understand just how
amazing past ocean life might have
looked
now the authors aren't actually making a
scientific assertion that this is what
all plesiosauria which for the record
weren't actually dinosaurs but adjacent
marine reptiles
looked like most please the asuria
likely had smooth skin
for better hydrodynamics but it's not
impossible some branches tried an ambush
approach
which may have favored better camouflage
an interesting possibility for sure
back on land here's a quite heavily
feathered speculative reinvention
of a therizinosaurus the therizinosaurus
looked quite menacing based on its
skeleton alone
thanks to the animal's absurdly long
claws which in the past excited artists
and caused them to make overly deadly
looking animals despite the fact the
animal wasn't a predator the thick layer
of feathers certainly makes the animal
look
less frightening and quite different
from their skeletal appearance
if you compare the gaunt skeleton of say
an owl however to the quite different
shape of the actual bird
you can start to see how such a
difference between skeleton and body
size
isn't too crazy a concept
therazinosaurus skeletons also have wide
hips
so it's been theorized they have sizable
physiques
beyond protofeathers all yesterdays also
explores the hypothetical that some
dinosaurs
like heterodontosaurus might have had
defensive quill-like structures not
unlike the defense of the modern
porcupine
seems hard to believe well a recently
exceptionally well-preserved specimen of
the early ceratopsian statakosaurus was
found with bristle-like quills on its
tail
the sitakasaurus is actually one of the
most completely reconstructed dinosaurs
and its appearance is
certainly not tame paleontologists don't
think those strange bristles on its tail
were for self-defense but it's certainly
possible that some genuses
like heterodontosaurus which we also now
know had some kind of spike like dermal
quills
could have used their bristles for
self-defense going even further into
hypothetical territory regarding
proto-feathers the authors imagine a
group of lielen asoria amicographica as
round furballs
quite different from the popular notion
of a dinosaur
far from fanciful speculation however
the author's recreation is based on
evidence that the lielan asoria lived in
a near polar region
and almost certainly had to endure
sub-zero temperatures
while one might look at such a
reconstruction and think that looks too
adorable for a dinosaur
the authors point out that the hesitancy
around depicting dinosaurs as
cute is potentially an overly limiting
one also incorporated into this design
liel and asoria tales were almost three
times as long as their body
for reasons paleontologists aren't quite
certain of
all yesterdays depicts their tales as
strange flagpole like tools for social
displays while easy to dismiss this
concept is overly speculative
the authors point out that while it's
certainly unlikely it's only so much
weirder than what you might see
anywhere else in nature but appearance
is only one half of the speculative
puzzle when it comes to dinosaurs
the authors observe that various unique
behaviors likely weren't preserved
within the fossil record
just think about the mating dances of
birds of paradise the unique halls of
whales or even something as simple as
the dung rolling of dung beetles and
you'll start to realize that behaviors
which give animals huge parts of their
identity
can often not be understood from remains
alone
and it stands to reason some dinosaurs
might have had similarly bizarre
behaviors which fall into the same
category
here's an intriguing speculative example
of elasmosaurus marine reptiles which
also aren't actually dinosaurs
behaving in a highly unusual manner here
the authors invent a scenario where the
elasmosaurus
lunge out of the depth and wave their
necks competing to prove who is the
strongest
older art of elasmosaurus sometimes
shows them holding their necks above the
water's surface with ease
but modern paleontology has proven these
animals had heavy bones and denser necks
which could only be lifted out of the
water with significant effort
so the author imagines these dinosaurs
exerting such a strain as a form of
social competition
of course this is absolutely and
unapologetically speculative yet
equivalently remarkable behavior is
likely lost
somewhere in our past in a similar vein
of speculative thought
here the authors imagine protoceratops
engaging in a tree-climbing behavior
there's no direct evidence for in the
slightest
and yet certain breeds of goats also
climb trees
a strange-looking behavior you wouldn't
guess the hoofed mammals would engage in
based on their body plans alone
and yes these modern goats they are not
a hoax they truly hang out in trees
it's something like this sort of
unexpected contact which might be absent
from the fossil record
on the subject of dinosaurs doing things
they're not known for
playing is certainly a significant
example instead of showing a dinosaur
striking a pose or getting attacked by a
predator
this recreation shows a chimerasaurus
enjoying a
simple role in the mud speculative
though this may seem
almost all living animals engage in some
form of play
both larger mammals but also various
species of birds reptiles and even fish
most animals have been observed taking
part in behavior for no practical
reason other than it seems to be fun so
dinosaurs even if they're sometimes
thought of creatures that lived in
constant battle with one another
almost certainly engaged in playful
behavior too
and here at the end is an image which
despite its simplicity
is one of the hardest to process it
shows a t-rex
just sleeping in a peaceful field but so
much of a classic perception of the
creature is of a roaring monster with
its jaw as a gate
ready to strike that we forget the
tyrannosaurus is also
just an animal and animals sleep
especially hunting animals who need to
conserve energy and therefore spend a
considerable amount of time
resting it's not certain if t-rexes
slept on their sides or not or if they
had this particular coloration
but it's still an intriguing image that
gets the viewer to think of the animal
as more than just a machine of death
ultimately science and speculation
aren't concepts in opposition to each
other
all paleontological art of long-extinct
creatures
is speculative to some degree and
thinking about interesting albeit
unusual possibilities can help us
appreciate all we know
and don't know about these remarkable
animals from the distant
past and that's the end of our glimpse
at the intriguing all yesterdays
if you like this content please consider
supporting cosmin nation conway's work
by purchasing a copy of the book
and by patronizing their other works and
social media which as always you can
find in the links below
also thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this entry please lend your support
and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious
see you in the next video
you